okay what I like to see in 2013 for
Africa's progress is the addressing
sanitation a lot of Africans are
starting to get cell phones but they
don't have toilets toilets is the
cheapest preventive medicine in the
world the history of human development
show us that longevity of a human life
was extended from 40 years to 65 years
after the invention of the flush toilet
so 25 more years of living was increased
because we have hygiene from a flush
toilet today sanitation remains one of
the failure in the Millennium
Development Goal in Africa with proper
sanitation and hygiene Africans can be
healthy productive and people who can
economically drive the country forward
by being able to work sick people are
unable to bring the country economically
forward so I would like to encourage
every country in Africa to emphasize
heavily on improvement of proper
sanitation for its people especially for
the woman thank you